Okay. Let's learn about another form element.
Instead of checkboxes, I want to use radio buttons.
So let's change the word from "checkbox" to "radio"
for these 3 inputs.
Okay. I've changed "checkbox" to "radio" for these 3 inputs,
for the type="radio",
and I've left the names the same: "q", "r", and "s".
Let's take a look at this in our browser.
Okay. Here we are in our browser, and you can see
we have our 3 radio buttons instead of checkboxes.
And I can turn a Radio on by clicking on it.
And if I click on a different radio button,
it also turns on.
Now that's probably not the behavior you were expecting.
Normally, when we have radio buttons,
they behave in a group.
These ones, obviously, aren't doing that.
What happens when I click the Submit button here?
You can see that they behave, actually, just like the checkboxes do:
q=on, r=on, and s=on.
So these are--basically what we here are checkboxes
that you can't be unchecked--
really convenient, right?
So now you know how radio buttons normally behave.
I should be able to select the second one and the first one should go off.
How do you think we might accomplish that?